[Music]
[Music]
that's called I really I hit something
here that stopped like a skateboard with
a rock Oh Johnny damn it that's good but
you never skateboarded I was a skater
what are you talking about no he was
recording and he was music hey guys that
looks cool pretty confident yeah like
Gerald went home I was like mama town I
need a need one and then they got him
one of the scooters which is just a
skateboard body but with the handle on
right and he showed up can you describe
to us what a scooter he forgets he turns
it on I was a skater for four years
right I was what okay name me a trick
ollie kickflip okay he just named the
basic and then when they moved to the
razors I think your request remembered
like that was just a less efficient
scooter yes a scooter which smaller bike
wheels and give it the wheels of a
rollerblade yeah just so you feel things
when they flip and hit you in the shin
yeah actually in Canada a little known
tweet they were very very expensive we
could not get razor scooters for the
first like year that's yeah so I went to
Plattsburgh and that's how you know your
country is a horrible place to live when
you go to Plattsburgh New York to buy
the cool was that it where we you know
like trade war with Canada no it was
just they just didn't happen it like in
ten to 64 games how much by the way hold
on a second let me okay half Asian water
bill rich black Garrett audio Wade
Gerald Morgan Joe Morgan a what we're
saying the tariffs I don't know how much
was it a Nintendo 64 game in the United
sleeve they were like 35 to 40 okay they
were like $69 people out there from
Canada terrible tell the folks below
number-one gold and I came out when it
was new I think for Christmas it was
like it was 69.95 and I remember because
one year I got Glover because they had
this whole ad campaign for Glover well
it was poor
right I got to the same thing it was
like hireable it was it was a video game
that was just awful
that's a Gerald gerald him is a bad line
okay no sirs better it was just a video
game it was similar like Mario 64 but
you would have to collect them it was it
was a it was a glove and you would
bounce a ball so terrible it was so
expensive and we had so little money
when I was a kid that I knew like that's
the video game I'm gonna get for the
year yeah
and yet I wanna and I want to kill
myself with it and then I have to and we
even have Google so I couldn't why I
would have to ask Jeeves how to kill
myself with an n64 game and he was no
help no it's a five-step process who's
got time for that
alright ended up switching to web
crawler all right by the way it is mug
club quarantine hashtag Macomb
quarantine is the month that's why we're
giving you all this content from the
paywall for free enter the promo code
quarantine you get $30 off that's our
biggest discount since the Fox ad
pocalypse
and if you are up for renewal please do
consider renewing we really do
appreciate it and yeah Canadiens set the
american straight below and we know
right yeah and you know what else was
crazy too we used to go to the platform
was called Champlain Mall but in
Plattsburgh we never had samples when I
grew up in Montreal really summer I went
through the first time ever experience a
1/2 a teriyaki I'm like yeah what we
couldn't even return things
Zellers was our Walmart nice I've got a
pinball machine this is sorry I just
didn't mean to start this way was our
Walmart an Ellen it was called tellers
it had the Canadians please sound off
the list remember this it has a zellers
bear what and I used up in nightmares
about this bears very creepy looking it
was like a Teddy Ruxpin on meth
oh nice they had a return policy that
wasn't there was no return policy and so
my parents got me one of those hand like
table ping-pong not ping pong a pinball
and it didn't work they ever did it
didn't work at all and so we returned it
my parents had the receipt yeah so this
is they could clearly see it was broken
and they charged us a 10% restocking fee
right there my parents like we don't
this is wrong all right are it's
Christmas or kid wants his toy okay
they exchanged at my dad says I'm gonna
check this right here in front of you
with the new one it's two did not work
20% no charge us another restocking fee
right there at sellers and so when
Walmart came in and closed them down I
thank the Lord above for the United
States of America Jesus Sam Walton thank
you how to open policy and for those who
don't who are not mug club members other
things talking about I'm gonna read your
check but this is something we do there
are a lot of a lot of shows that we do
and a lot of jokes that don't quite make
air mostly I'm on Thursday or what you
see on YouTube or sometimes they don't
even make air behind the pay water mug
club at all and they just find their way
and I should be clear some of them are
because they're way too offensive in
many ways both sides of the bed when I
said let's do mug Club quarantine yeah
and here's the logo be a little surgical
mask right I never know if feels like a
hey hold on that could be a fence if I
said it's a little surgical mask in a
rice paddy hat and bill I'm waiting for
him he goes you put a zipper on that
thing make it a zipper head other times
not
can I ask I know you already asked
people to put things down below in the
comments yeah and I hijacked that as
well if anyone wants to help me on the
legal side here are any of these jokes
ones that should not even have made it
into scrap yard yeah I need hell it's a
good point that we can keep this out let
us know and off the air which of the
following bits and/or jokes or tidbits
anecdotes if you will should never have
seen the light of day at all you can't
answer all of them all of the above
options welcome many of you for the
first time to scrapyard
[Music]
I have actually never take that fade off
their quarter block yard I have never
seen that intro with the Mohammed
picture in the coat he's like he did
with the goat he wants I think you're
fought while had expired
once this shut down he already has his
application accepted to the Young Turks
oh no you won't
hope you like nose jobs so keep in mind
some of these obviously may not seem
topical anymore because some of them are
very old but a couple of weeks ago
Madonna made a video from her bathtub
telling us that we should all be a
little more like the coronavirus that's
the thing about Cove it doesn't care
about how much you are astute and now
very much like the coronavirus I also
want to kill me horrible and I want a
chlorophyll and she's just the one I am
appreciate that she she ditched her
English accent without her Saginaw
Michigan yeah we all know that people
speak like Queen Elizabeth from Saginaw
Michigan there was a 50/50 shot like the
police would have found her dead in the
tub after film yes definitely yeah
sounded like her final confession
well one can hope so while his by the
way I know her I've spent some time with
her parents they've run a lovely winery
and I believe are very ashamed with
their daughter well this has they should
be
while his trial was going on she
originally this was written
hey this is in the news but it's not in
the No
while his trial was going on at some
point
Harvey Weinstein there it is said he
once read a 546 page book about Winston
Churchill in one day Wow his lawyers are
calling it the smart rapist defense we
have to compliment a joke is it really
your jokes complimented a lot but yeah I
do Harold sets up gel delivers the
punchline and the reaction is it's so
good for you this one and now my
confidence is shot but a man was
hospitalized this one's an evergreen so
doesn't matter man was hospitalized when
a woman bit his neck after he peed on
her yoga mat oh this comes from the
Baltimore Sun charges have been pressed
by the man who told police that he was
intoxicated and did not know what room
he was in I don't see what the big deal
is said judge our Kelly now it should be
noted or this is this was the
alternative right punch line was it she
noted that this was from the latest
episode of celebrity judge art Kelly
there you go there you go and here's the
issue is because often we write so we
write like three four five jokes right
and you see the ones that make air so
that's that's the a material and then
sometimes you write many jokes and end
just none of them are even passable none
of them could even pass as possible I
tend to just get an email says we'll
consider this for scrapyard
it's not even automatic preview the
email of anyone involved with production
you mean that's not real there now
you're not supposed to he says have an
idea I send him through the ladder with
credit contact form he tries to book me
for a gig in Schenectady weird
you think Gerald's gonna find out that
we've just been feeding his jokes The
Young Turks they keep copying so weird
but they seem happy with it
back back when the coronavirus thing
just holding the coronaviruses you know
the thief heard of it was just getting
big actress I don't like this one
actress Hilary Duff criticized quote
millennial aspirants who were still
partying instead of self quarantine
that's right if they don't listen to
every doctor on the planet maybe they'll
listen to Lizzie McGuire
ouchie I don't know if you can tell like
you I don't even believe in hey you need
to break a couple of these and just do
an episode for me and Gerald because we
like all these we need to like rat out
who wrote them in the future how did
audio wade contribute to that show map
nine times out of ten it's a joke that
includes the words hot hairy ass like
your dad watches the show does he know
that you write the the hot hairy ass
through line and you said no we had the
joke who was it who said this is their
daughter coming out yeah it was
Elizabeth Smart who was kidnapped and
sexually abused for several years and it
was a story about her dad coming out as
gay and she that's right yeah and she
was talking about how difficult that was
so this is a true story we have so we
don't really have a like a live studio
audience but we have I don't know if we
can even show with that camera we have
like about eight seats there where the
producers sit or sometimes family
members of the crew and so the joke
there was Elizabeth Smart I think saying
it was my dad's gay this is the worst
thing that's ever happened to me
and we had a lesbian in the staff at the
time and she was roaring with laughter
oh my gosh
which didn't surprise me because she's
gay it surprised me because most
lesbians have no senses of humor and she
was the exception to the rule there yeah
gays are fun lesbians usually not you
know as funny as if anyone comments and
they're like I didn't think it was funny
then they're proving the rule yeah
undoubtedly a carpet muncher remember
the gun protests in Virginia yeah well
eventually governor Ralph Northam 'z
assault weapons ban that he was pushing
remember after that failed when he heard
the news governor north and was so sad
he lynched himself that's a net pot he
was racist you didn't know if you didn't
know he was so sad he burned a cross on
his own lawn I think that's the winner
in the comments the good the bad and the
ugly you know it just shows you you
never know what's gonna work because I
thought Lynch - I thought that lynched
himself was funnier than magorium I vote
for that at least I thought Lizzie
McGuire there's the other one Haylie
Duff mixed up the Duff's in my head of
the Duff's I shouldn't have their
information like can we get rid of that
for for CDC statistics or something and
I know that one of the Duff's this is
how this is every one of you should just
kick my ass this should be like an ACME
cartoon was just a pile of dust and then
it's a bloody corpse I know that Haylie
Duff was on seventh heaven
know why Hilary Duff's sister she was
the one that did this take your leg
after she was a lip-syncing on the fact
that you know that no no that's not
that's Ashley racial I can't remember
it's like a Teen Vogue show now what the
hell's going on here now it's just a bad
show
like dance thank you thank you trying to
trying to be coy about the fact that he
has all of a Simpsons I'm not except
among any of my peers can we high-five
here white nor black quarter black you
have no home I know you do that's why
you need me man we love you if you need
me so that I don't thrust you out into
the cold world so this happened back in
February
Michaela Spielberg not Michaela Peterson
by the way if one of them daughter to
the most prolific director producer of
all time the other one loves rib eye
loves loves rib eye
vitamin C nothing wrong with that fake
news so mikheil Berg no actually and of
course I love Jordan Peterson his
daughter to actual probably be on the
show it's just the carnivore diet you
know um I just just wasn't good for my
stool Mikayla Spielberg daughter of
Steven Spielberg she announced that she
is attempting to become a sex worker
maybe this could have been avoided if
her father spent a little more time
raising his kids a little less time
executive producing cats which is not so
much a joke as it is trying to highlight
the monstrosity joke is two on this on
the nose right yeah like literally
everyone regrets his time with cats it's
two on the whiskers know who's got five
wants to hurt me by the way I thought
like if you were becoming a set like the
bars pretty low to be a sex worker she's
failing all this paperwork reunion I
have no idea what a union is it $10.99
that yeah yeah you probably kind of
tracked her now choose your bring your
own equipment produce terrible show club
quarantine month at the Apollo
that's just all right according to
doctors by the way putting potatoes up
your butt may your hemorrhoids won't but
really if you if walking around all the
day if you needed a doctor to tell you
that then I'm afraid you'd Freddy need a
doctor different kind though also stop
using up all the wet wipes in the studio
bathroom Tim from HRM it's okay the
barracuda that's one always filled with
tater tots
it's also why you always he goes in
this is the kind of stuff that makes
scrap car was that his rectum is similar
to a toaster oven the intro with the
strap you still here we want absolves me
no responsibility for in a promotional
tie-in with I really hate this one I did
terrible about this next one is that
this whole thing that is now scratch it
was this it was a seven plus one I don't
know what we were thinking uh smoke I'd
still like no one is bad well then too
much of a leaden in a promotional time
with Buffalo Wild Wings rap group Bone
Thugs and harmony has changed their name
to boneless thugs in harmony oh that's
the real story yeah yeah they also
announced their summer tour alongside
run KFC Shake Shack mafia and Southwest
chicken salads with attitude has no idea
as to what it feels like to want to
swallow a knife when a joke that bombs
giving air support I appreciate it Chuck
was awesome thing was great on that I
mean the joke sucked
I appreciate it well director any else
you want to get your system here with
scrapyard before we go to any kind of I
want to do this one you might do this
one yeah
just a second just so you know I changed
it right before air because it wasn't it
wasn't offense it was offensive but it's
enough so I'm just letting you know all
right I just wanna give you enough time
so you could see it okay alright
half-asian bill so director Quentin
Tarantino and his wife have welcomed
their first child was super footballs in
the first year Satine Tarantino and his
wife have welcomed their first child
that's not yeah for Fox News Tarantino
said the birth was the most beautiful
experience of his life however it could
have used more blood and n words yeah
could always use
all the tanks floating human beings you
know what this was was like I think this
would if I'm not mistaken it was we had
a really late night right it might have
been after the stream we were writing
them and I think it stemmed from me
doing like a mild Quentin Tarantino and
Brett and Mick Brautigan
for some reason assumed that we had the
brought the budget for the prosthetics
to make me look like what you don't
really he's more blood and n-word
you know without that face that's been
twisted from decades of evil this right
sometimes you get the face you deserve
and then sometimes in content he knows
case you get the face that nobody would
wish that on my worst enemy
my worst enemy before we go to the meat
segment audio way do we have anything
from from life yeah yeah so MJ says have
any of you Steven Garrett bill way taken
the in Gerald gerald her to take any
political compass quiz and would you be
open to doing a segment on it like you
did with the white privilege and
microaggressions quizzes you know I
think didn't ben shapiro do that i think
so you've so yeah and so i think i did
it a long time ago back when this was
still on radio so you know just more
proof positive that he copies me I guess
we could revisit it if we wanted to be
on original times to you and better so
similar she just make Gerald do it and
then well the rest of us will just roast
him while he's doing yes you know if you
guys have we've seen of people in the
comments section you want me to do the
political compass quiz sure
my guess is I'll probably considered a
basic [ __ ] traditional conservative
yeah libertarian surprised like people
are often surprised because I just say
the weed thing is what people get upset
like listen I actually think states
should be able to legalize weed and I
think it's silly that it's a it's a
scheduled schedule 1 substance and I
think that CBD shows a lot of promise I
just think that people aren't
responsible when they tell kids like
it's looser than a beard no no some
people can have can smoke and go crazy
that's that's true it's a side effect
it's not common I just but I also think
states should be able to legalize heroin
yeah if they want to I
don't think heroines a good idea so
people often surprises recommend
libertarian legal disclaimer steven
crowder does not recommend yeah it does
off your stage in hard drug use things
or is the lighter brighter its crack or
nothing record I've just know there's a
number on at the bottom of the screen if
you order your crack now from LA north
credit calm slash Month Club you get a
free toy Wow it's just mark rack promo
code Rocklin alright and we might be cut
with a little PCP because we cut costs
where we can so someone says recent
scribe to mug club with the promo code
love you guys audio wave you should
release an album I didn't know this said
those but didn't read ahead no I no
plans now oh you don't have the voice of
an angel
thank you um mail mixed with the
sweetest of honey's Wow David is a very
good voice and it's not arrogant about
it either like weight is very
encouraging and helping other people
with that someone like them but we've
talked about this doing doing an album
because we have like 20 tracks but the
thing is it's so hard do we put it in it
you know that's nothing let us know the
kind of like a chat on YouTube here
should we put it on on Spotify I don't
know the best way to do it Spotify I
would we could just make it exclusive
for people who are mug Club members so
that way my club members don't have to
pay anything
and you can just download on the site
but I have no idea how to do this so I
mean seriously I every time we end up
doing parodies I would buy a CD of our
but yes like it would be yes I would
have it on you'd put it to be hilarious
you'd put it next to your Batman
soundtrack and all for one debut album
and nothing else on the shelf yes but I
would actually probably ask I'd be like
hey since I'm on the show can I get like
a free copy like a bootleg nessuno maybe
I wouldn't actually be overpaid
I'll just ham it out of your check well
you know let us know how we should I
don't know anything about this do the
podcast and that goes up on all the
profiles but no music it's a master it
right thing is it even still a thing the
iTunes Store like can you buy albums yes
no I don't think it is
you can buy maybe you still can I don't
know thanks a lot
Taylor Swift oh you're such a disrupter
let's go all that out of our system let
us know if you ever want to see another
scrap yard again let's go to the meet
and see that was a short stinger except
we bill was laughing on control I was we
had to redo the stinger thinking about
it slightly off-color joke about Native
American naming that's all it took
naming methods yeah they call them
methods let's be honest you know take a
shot of Windex whatever comes out call
it a day humor is ayahuasca a Native
American thing
I think it's South American South
America is it
what's the Vision Quest the Native
Americans take a Vision Quest sure this
achill late 80s arcade system no that
was a real math Matthew Modine but it's
an actual thing they do a Vision Quest
yeah I don't know about that no I do no
no I mean I don't know anything about it
oh yeah well yeah because you don't do
drugs aside from those prescribed with
coyote gross looking for a lifeline
because I didn't want to stop on not
knowing yeah I need alcohol I don't know
anything about drugs peyote will you
tell my PCP DMT which opens the trunk to
his Jeep young gun don't let my lawyer
see this so I think we have I have no
idea
Gerald what you were reading it you
should yes so uh question here's my
question say before I move on a little
bit and I know people will be upset in
this controversial and yeah I don't
really care um at what point do you
think that we need to consider reopening
the American economy when do you think
the ill effects of staying shut down
could be worse than the virus itself by
the way everyone here cares about every
single life lost yeah okay none of us
hate old people none of us think the
viruses I just want to be clear about
all that being said I do think there is
some both foot so
past week Donald Trump has been talking
about a night by the way I just love if
you didn't watch the press or yesterday
I'm thinking let me know if what do you
think I'm running the Donald Trump press
briefings on this channel or insider
bits live because CNN cutout you should
to do the job that the Melea won't do
yes did you see him present that video
last night he was he presented he came
in with a video of his timeline and a
lot just be really clear because a lot
in a lot of people saw the video they
didn't see the feet of him presenting
the video to the room see that yeah I
did says he's there's a video that comes
up and shows a timeline and he put the
timeline says you know in States China
travel ban and he goes playing a montage
like will Lou here that in Deitz the
media where they're say you should be
more worried about the flu this is not
again and Nancy Pelosi saying you know
I'll come down to Chinatown and at one
point there's someone from CBS who says
you should worry more about the flu and
he goes any point what we mean he was
defending himself come on they started
it this world could use a little bit
more petty childish childish childish
what Cornish game hen what's not Jewish
so he throughout this past week and
again when you remove the Trump isms I
think that we're Betsy entirely
reasonable he's mentioned to date of May
first but nothing concrete he has talked
about entertaining the idea of reopening
certain portions of the economy let's
take it in context here's what he said I
don't know that I've had a bigger
decision but I'm gonna surround myself
with the greatest minds not only the
greatest minds but the greatest minds in
numerous different businesses including
the business of politics and reason and
we're going to make a decision and
hopefully it's going to be the right
decision I will say this I want to get
it open as soon as we can great minds
from politics and reason and it stamps
like note to self hire writer from
reason yeah Mitchell SP great side birds
I also hear Matt kibbe has them but
enough everybody here the good folks
what respective returns and sideburns
throw a previous rockabilly cover band
into Z so that was pretty reasonable
when you remove the great industries
like politics philosophy Plato ready at
home I love that service that's not even
excuse me but the media reacted as you
would expect them to react as though
that which wasn't pretty I think
measured response saying at some point
we need to weigh we need a balanced
lives and livelihoods but the media has
reacted I mean there's no way we can
even start to think about opening things
back up unless we've got a few the
former reality shows we can tell the
story about American resilience what he
lacks in impotence of the dead he makes
up for in his insistence that the
country will come back stronger than
ever and instead just wet with matter
the notion is once again telling people
Holder he's going to decide to reopen
the economy soon based on his instincts
president Trump's new date for getting
the country back to work narrow burst of
stage such as me we're saying fine on
May 1st because they're worried we would
just have another outbreak again in the
hospital systems would be overwhelmed
over over again you are correct he was
he is Benjamin at the end of that
segment it was just a suit with a tie
and a head oh baby yeah and it was a
very neat 'less budget yeah it wasn't
recouped that belongs I'm good morning
mutt club he's wearing a bathrobe the
gap is shrinking it's the race to the
middle so um this is remarkable let's
look at this let's look and see if there
is even a case remotely for reopening
the economy or when that case should be
made or if we can contrary to what
Rachel Maddow says think about you can't
even think we can't even know start to
think I think we can start and I think
we can think we can do both I think
therefore I'm not Rachel Maddow so
that's delineating it's how it works
back to was it play-doh
back to fill philosophy humor
you're not to eat I like how
controversial it is to be thinking right
listen I can't even think people I just
want to let you know just listen to me
Rachel Maddow I'll tell you the answers
don't think yeah but I respect you pit
you don't even add mutton check let's
look at this you people just throw
numbers in a vacuum it's what the media
has done and I think what you context
matters you've heard me talk about this
consistently context over content when
you take the numbers into context the
United States is actually doing
surprisingly well you can focus on raw
total numbers and then I think one
person when I tweeted an article that
was removed from medium I said well why
are using the per capita numbers matter
more than total because of a country has
30 million people and a country has 330
million people the per capita numbers
kind of matter it does just a little I
think it's more relevant you let me know
which metrics you think are more
relevant that being said we're still
doing better than Europe which part all
of it except for Germany which surprises
me but I think there's a coup in the
works keep your eyes on them the deaths
per capita per 1 million and you can go
to World a meter and hit this use this
metric to list them I think is what's
most important because testing rates
aren't accurate infection rates aren't
accurate we don't necessarily know how
accurate the antibody tests are the
death rate the mortality rate of course
is a based on a percentage of how many
will die versus how many people test
positive so what is concrete that is
undeniable is how many people have died
from the virus and then specifically to
put into context how many people per
capita so you don't see that number
covered a whole lot from the media why
well a couple of things when you do see
it covered this is important too you see
a graph like this this is how its
presented let's bring this up so look at
that that graph looks pretty bad but
keep that up there for a little bit the
reason that that graph looks that way is
that they are tracking from when deaths
registered you know this is what's
called with McClung logo log read these
words have never pronounced terrific I
have very little interaction with human
beings outside of the studio I read
words and as you should bring that back
up
notice something there's the same
distance between 1 and 10 as ten to a
hundred now I understand why that's
necessary if you have a graph where the
number is so exponential that it would
all of a sudden end up off the graph
right that's not the case here let's
look at the exact
same numbers and by the way that
presentation of course favors smaller
countries at masks sort of the contrast
in the United States in support entries
look at the exact same numbers in our
brilliant researcher reg created a sort
of properly spaced linear y axis
counting again while we're talking about
response time which is what the media is
talking about from the day of the first
death since that's what matters as far
as response time do you notice something
notice that yeah that looks like the you
know is lower than everyone by a
significant margin with the exception of
Germany does that say we're losing
exactly this no it's like golf bill you
want to be lower there's someone right
there no we're not gonna be second to
anyone certainly not certainly not
France looking polls those numbers up
change that graph myself well and all
you hear basically is that the United
States has the largest number of cases
in the world of the largest number of
deaths whatever they tend to throw and
I'm like guys you're even if that were
true even if we had the highest yeah
they've got four times I mean look I
read it on Bloomberg don't trust you oh
that's true you didn't believe it at
first but now I believe it thank you
Bloomberg honey for telling me what to
do yeah well yeah I love how we actually
act as a bloomberg was written by
Bloomberg right like the reason
Bloomberg is valuable is because he has
nothing to do with it yes so virtually
all of Europe with the exception of
Germany again not a hoax the virus but
it certainly at no point has been as bad
as the media made it out to be keep in
context 2.5 million or if we implement
social distancing measures right away
extreme the minimum is one hundred two
hundred forty thousand when the number
was reduced that wasn't in the absence
of social distancing that was taking
into account socializing some more
examples this matters because just like
climate change for Florida supposed to
be gone we weren't supposed to have some
kind of a rainbow fish I don't know
there sadly still there great lakes
record highs same techniques by the way
being used as people who if you say I'll
go back to the climate change I think
New York this was a good example even
where Donald Trump I thought that he was
wrong
we're all so glad that's petty so New
York they said that they needed 40,000
ventilators Trump sent four thousands
they don't even use all them but he
questioned their need for them I'm
watching the presser going that's not a
smart move because they say they need
40,000 ventilators I don't know it said
we might have to look into what they're
doing the vent
lehder never one goes how dare you
question the numbers and I was even like
wait why would you question the numbers
that's a losing battle you know why
because any less than four yeah yeah 10%
of the ventilators they claim they need
it and he was saying we should keep them
here so we could send up the states who
need them not give them as a stockpile
with no pre pre-existing terms to
barbell nipple specifically bar
beautiful I thought they were both
barbells yeah are they both barbells I
don't know I don't know let's keep the
rumor live as though it's accurate
absolutely one it's like if you got
question any of the information so
states can say oh my god there's gonna
be a panic yeah I say I need a lot more
than you actually need what we're seeing
now like no he was right on all these
points what to be clear so he didn't say
Blasio said yeah we didn't we didn't
we're good no de Blasio said that but my
point now is that when Rachel Maddow and
company come out and say well we can't
possibly reopen the economy I mean how
could you ever possibly it's like guys
you haven't been right on Donald Trump
doesn't care about dying patients right
because he wants to do that he was
saying I don't think you need all of
these ventilators right now that's what
if you do we'll send them right and
right now they're the federal stockpile
over 10,000 ventilators but if they'd
have said so in other words they would
have sent their entire stockpile to New
York right without the ability to send
them nobody else you might need them de
Blasio said we're good
here's another thing some of these are
anecdotal but these are things that you
heard in the media and then when they
turned and they turn out to not come to
fruition they just move on like Florida
still there we check Seattle was a big
one remember that you saw all this
publicity they set up an emergency to
her and 50 bed sort of army field
hospital for the surge never saw a
patient packed up and left after nine
days now I want to be clear that's not
saying that no surge could happen but it
was predicted concretely that unless you
get them what they need right unless
40,000 ventilators unless we open up
extra hospitals people will die
why don't you care about people dying
that was what was sold to us and in
nearly every instance it's been a
fracture right a fraction of what
they've claimed by the way speaking of
fractions is because it has nothing to
do with them it was a bad pivot it was a
that so notification about it all
notifications and of course quarantine
is a promo code right now all of this
mmm
if you haven't been convinced
all of us is available for free this
month mug Club corn yeah Mon Cubans
Benjamin Button at the end of that last
video the guy with the boat I'm the
bathrobe said if we if we opened this
economy back up on May first we need to
specify that I did yes which one well
there was one we all agreed was Benjamin
Button there was one person out there
who didn't understand what I said no it
that was for you um so he said basically
if we open this back up all of the
hospitals are again going to be overrun
I'm like wait a minute can you show me
all of the hospitals being overrun now I
mean there may be some examples of that
but very very few and this is those are
higher their beds or ICU beds are at
higher higher fill rates yeah then they
were in the past so that may mean that
hospital goes from a typical fill rate
of like 57 percent of hospital beds are
occupied right now compared to 67 or it
might go from 67 to 86 and so they're
not necessarily ready to handle this
load right but it doesn't mean that all
of the beds are filled and they need
another hospital and that's what we've
been sold so the numbers in context
matter well and just because it's
happening in New York doesn't mean it's
happening in Des Moines right so it's
like all hospitals are being overrun
there may be pockets that don't Sully
Des Moines fine reputation that I am in
the same breath as New York City
I just kidding there's no song for Des
Moines after the half of the first
person to Des Moines here's a here's an
exception by the way in in Europe Sweden
so Sweden is still actually doing better
than many of the surrounding countries
despite not having a lockdown and I know
there's tough to compare all countries
because it's tough to compare their
their health care systems and in Sweden
is actually more free enterprise based
and a lot of places out there a lot of
people don't realize that certainly as
far as how they treat businesses
something people don't take into account
South Korea South Korea didn't do a full
shutdown now granted they Doc's their
citizens but they also decided to
protect the most vulnerable among them
quarantine knows people I suggested that
here with my Korean doctor everyone
thought that I didn't care about old
people dying so joke's on you because I
don't know why it's on you I still care
about anyone dying I want to be clear
let me just backtrack this old people
shouldn't die ever
if I were president no one would ever
die not sure you can make that claim
credit 24 so we do need this the numbers
that we've been presented brighten you
up to say okay in context how much does
how
does this paint a total picture right
what can we predict versus what we know
and that's what matters when you're
weighing lives versus livelihoods so we
don't know exactly what the total death
count will be we don't know what the
mortality rate is we know that it's
exceedingly low for people who don't
have diabetes or pre-existing conditions
heart conditions below the age of 80 in
Italy below the age of 70 in most
countries depends where you go if you
are under the age of 70 let's play it
safe and you have any pre-existing
conditions you'll likely be fine wear a
mask
although CDC said don't wear masks let's
compare that what we know jobless claims
17 million that's in PhotoPass weeks
we've hit that number I believe this
week finally here's a percentage that we
do know small businesses right who say
that their business will still be intact
still exist if the crisis lasts six
months as that young man Rachel Maddow
was suggesting other than groceries for
some reason there's thirty three percent
say they'll be in business when it comes
to hotels 27 percent of personal
services 22 percent of restaurants and
bars 15 percent of other and to be clear
there's a plus or minus variance of four
percent because of untoward massage
parlors I don't know why they bring you
to excuse the sampling data mostly
Haitian people are still visiting the
Chinese right but the Census Bureau
wanted to make that visit so that's why
the way people saying it will still be
open 33 percent of hotels will still be
open Wow not that close yeah I wonder
whether I have this right yes will still
exist after six months so this is
important these these aren't just
hypothetical numbers these have
real-world impact and I don't know why
we are not taking into account when
every other day of the year you can tune
into Vox you can tune into CNN where
they talk about food deserts and they
talk about poverty they talk about
unemployment how that leads to mental
illness and all of the other auxilary
effects right severe unemployment leads
to whose phone is that
[Laughter]
do a lot yes Lipstein yes and what that
means to play us out Molly Crewe you've
been in broadcasting for 30 years and
you know my Seth Meyers
[Laughter]
it's not a racial thing when they try to
say it's about oppressed classes no but
severe unemployment power it leads to an
increased burglaries suicides
homelessness overall poor public health
and alone those people waterboard more
likely to have heart conditions more
likely to be obese more likely have
diabetes which means that you will have
far less resistance to the actual
contagion like bug that we've been told
us coming around the corner yeah and
when economies crashed even we've got
this threat world history when economies
crash people do really stupid things
right right they allow people like Adolf
Hitler who years before was already put
in jail because they rejected his ideas
to get out and come into power they
allow people like Mussolini to come in
and say we're gonna restore Italy to the
prominence that it once had and say well
alright things are really bad maybe this
guy can do it they do write really
stupid things no you don't take that for
granted that's true
any thoughts on that since you come from
the word the country with all the
dictators yeah hey I'm gonna tell you
dictatorship it's gonna lead clearly to
having lower Corona deaths just look at
my friends in China yes I'm just saying
the numbers speak for themselves and hey
you know we're good at math nary a wet
market to be found um here's something
else I think you'll see a different tune
being sung now why because this is
what's so amazing to me I mean and not
ironic like the Alanis Morissette song
or take a look that's coincidental not
ironic we get that you have a Canadian
pass because you know your foreign
there's something exotic about you know
it's like the whole lot for the whole
weird al' chic look ya know but it's not
really ironic to rain on your wedding
day that's an unfortunate coincidence
this is actually lucky because of all
because of this pandemic right now and
because the fact that they have
predicted these surges and they've tried
to prepare for them hospitals are now
furloughing or laying off workers so
this economy is directly affecting
health care workers because there aren't
enough jobs to go around and then this
is another one that is to me and I'm not
taking any pleasure in this what I'm
saying is that when you just throw out
hypothetical numbers and you tell
everyone that they have to
beat to the beat of your drum they have
to dance to the beat of March to the D
I'm very tired what am I saying
peyote here's another thing I read this
article take know join anyone being
unemployed unless it's a unless is this
next person so journalism has been hit
hard and I use journalism in the loosest
sense of the word so hard that
Democratic senators and journalists are
now demanding a bailout there was an
article at hospitals you better you
better save the local news first off why
second let's keep in mind these people
already receive the same kind of
stimulus checks right now keep in mind
they receive the individual checks and
the small business loans that are
available in other words that's not
enough and I do think that it's ironic
considering that you told everybody else
who said maybe we should look at
reopening the economy that they were
effectively Hitler reincarnated now
you're saying hey that the economy has
affected you you should be bailed out of
the taxpayer expense no no no no what
we're all in this together at this point
right journalists included at least you
should be because your job is certainly
non-essential well I connected he
register the / Poughkeepsie Harold
that's you merged the Democrats were
against bailing out big corporations and
now they're trying to bail out these
these journalistic I don't know they're
only against be a useful corporation Oh
useful to them I'm against bailing out
any corporations how about that unless
the unless the government stepped in and
said shut down your corporation right
nobody nobody picked in this corporation
well then fine that's totally different
situation but they were saying the money
should just go directly to the people
and not through businesses that provide
jobs to the people but unless it's this
right want to save them now yeah not not
as it applies to the West Texas times oh
I'm running out of mayonnaise a very
urgent the Schenectady register to have
some power the Des Moines Morning News I
mean I can keep going to work is it yes
I love it so late City Gazette it's just
like
nineteen wives in a room and typewriter
and one overworked husband they but this
energy is amazing one just types it and
any other wife goes perky one per letter
handles vowels I guess it's like the New
Deal it's just jobs everywhere this is a
horrible segment yep
just amazing to me that you know they
want the economy to stay closed for thee
but not for me and by the way this
doesn't help health care workers it
doesn't help health care workers and
this is one thing too it doesn't help
health care workers who are honestly at
the front lines trying to do a good job
for some other nurse to go out there and
take an Instagram picture of the bags
under eyes and say we're all at death's
door
when other health care workers saying no
no we don't want to waste research we
don't need 40,000 ventilators someone
who's not trying to politicize it
because that actually would be more
inventory than we could take care of
right now
unfortunately everyone's afraid to speak
out why because they'll tell you that
you don't like anyone that you want old
people to die that's not true and this
is just like the climate change issue
that I wanted to come back to and then I
think we have a Glenn Beck coming up and
through this you know climate change
listen it's not enough to say hey yeah
sure the world is warming it's not
enough to say but you know what I think
humans might have an impact it's not
enough to say hey you know what we might
actually have a vested interest here and
trying to find more renewable energy but
if you say you know what I just don't
believe that the Kyoto Protocol the
Montreal agreement Kyoto Protocol slash
Paris Accord is going to fix the issue
of climate change and we certainly
shouldn't try and deal with climate
change at the expense of human life or
human beings who create industries that
innovate which is ultimately what will
solve our energy problem in the long run
all of a sudden you're an apostate
you're a pariah you have no business
speaking even at the table it's the same
thing that's happening here right now
we're not saying that this is a hoax
what we are saying and I've been saying
this all along and I see a lot of
conservatives now sort of walking it
back there's and this is this is
something we need to get ahead of of
course we need to be ahead of this and I
think we've done a pretty good job but
we've always been saying and I can I
maintain this I won't be shamed into
panic
we need to and people don't like saying
this because there are lives at stake
there are always lives at stake every
when you make maneuvers
in war there are lives at stake when you
when you decide who goes to the
lifeboats first you still have to make a
risk assessment call with lives at stake
and in this case when we know the
ramifications of the kind of
unemployment and crippling economy that
could be seen for generations to come
there does need to be a balance between
saving lives from a virus of none of the
models have proven to be accurate versus
the livelihoods of everyone who will be
alive which is 99.999999 I don't even
have a calculator that goes that far I
was too busy spelling boobs on upside
down so fun people 99.99 I lost mention
of people who will still be around after
this virus and what I what I think is
most important is anyone out there and
people who've been feeling this for a
long time I want you to speak out about
this I wanted to speak out with everyone
that you know in your personal lives any
platform you have just try and present
it from a compassionate point of view
and with balance and when these people
like Rachel Maddow talk about Donald
Trump for brian Stelter literally so
that donald trump has nonetheless or
they say you know what if you believe
that you don't care about the country
you know i'm talking about all of the
people out there who are scraping for a
job they are clawing and biting to try
and preserve their livelihood don't say
that when i say we need to take their
lives into account their livelihoods
that i don't care about the country they
or the country and that's the point okay
let's go to glenn beck after my knee is
like
[Music]
let's all try to Waffen let's all try
some wall food let's all try some Waffen
against the wealth of firearms quality
firearm engineering for over a century
sleek lines butter smooth triggers an
unparalleled reliability Walther created
the first semi-automatic pistol in 1908
and they've made the best ever since so
the next chance you have demand lovely
and proudly I'll try the Walther let's
all try some father
because they are
[Music]
I feel like I don't really have the hips
like the dancing people move their hips
like oh my gosh it's like a it's like a
bobblehead doll but on to the head it's
the hips I'm pretty loose in the
shoulders shoulder work yeah because I
can dislocate them or because of my
connective tissue damage so it's fun
right at least you can use it at least I
can use it our next guess you know him
of course he's been on the show many
times and I put him for gosh probably
going in it a decade now Wow I have no
idea
I feel old but he's older because yeah
it's right here Glenn Beck on the
Twitter and of course you know him the
blaze he has his shows that are they're
both his radio show and his television
show his new book is arguing with
socialists which I don't know I don't
have the book because I didn't get the
link for it until recently so I don't
have a physical copy mr. Glenn Beck how
are you sir very good I can't believe we
didn't deliver a copy to you yeah I know
I didn't want anyone there to be fired
but I assume you'll handle business I
don't know I'm a little busy polishing
my nipple rings
okay so I have two things I want to go
to your tattoos and the nipple rings but
before that where's the book available
right just to be clear any place that is
open okay no open you can buy it it said
books to Amazon Barnes & Noble wherever
okay good good good yeah by the way
there's a there's an amazon barnes &
noble cafe that recently it's barnes
noble cafe right next to a starbucks and
the barnes noble cafe has its limited ly
less books or magazines than cafe items
have you seen these recently Glen yes I
have there's one if there's one in South
Lake down here and it's like 40,000
square feet and most of is just for
coffee now right yes exactly it's it's
just as we proudly carry Starbucks I
mean whether there's a Starbucks right
next door I was here for the book yes
and I thought oh we have a coffee when I
go buy a book only but there are no
books it's just coffee coffee either so
okay I want to go back to your tab we'll
go back to the book but before that
nipple rings we were done with this
before we went on air you think that mr.
governor
you think it's an actual nipple ring I
think he might have had like like I
think I think it's yeah no I think it's
two and I think it's a one here and one
here and they're big they're nasty and I
don't want to think about them honestly
I mean they may have started here but I
think they're actually down here now yes
yeah and that was even more disturbing
it's added wavy and yeah he's a he's a
standing devil for National Geographic
specials they just put in just guests
from up close you might I wouldn't have
so much of a problem with it if he
didn't hide it
like if someone nipple rings Folsom
Street Fair let your freak freak flag
fly but you're trying to act like the
kind of person who would be at a Barnes
& Noble cafe but you have the nipple
rings it's like pick a lane mm-hmm well
minute wait a minute wait a minute I
don't want to see him dress like one of
the Village People I don't want to see
him shirtless in chaps and Nick nipple
rings doing the governor's work that is
a gross mischaracterization trying to
hide it that is a gross
mischaracterization of what happens at
the Folsom Street Fair it is a
family-friendly event how dare you sir I
go there I have my kids for direct drag
time story time whatever how are you
saying he's hiding them well cuz he's in
other words if he just lifted it said
hey look at my nipple rank big deal and
moved on but they're in a golf shirt I
think he's made a mistake he made the
mistake of bringing the wrong fabric
golf shirt like if he'd have one of the
traditional sort of cotton but he wore
the peak cotton so it's very sheer so I
don't think he intended that and then
you know he didn't answer
he's answer for his nipple bond yes yeah
if he would have answered that it would
have been fine but it still would have
been creepy and I don't want to think
about his nipple rings anymore well I'll
be sure to bring delight in the
interview because it's a spite know
you've a lot of tattoos right so you
know nipple rings no I have ones what I
thought we have the one in your calf
right I have one okay around my ankle
okay no no no not that you've ever seen
well I remember you showing it because I
was a wee red fox and I was a kind of
like I guess sort of sub
co-hosting because you were answering
questions with the audience and so I was
fielding questions and one of them was
about your tattoo and I had never known
that you had a tattoo and you showed it
and what is it on your calf ankle I mean
it's it's a pretty it's a pretty
elaborate tattoo okay we can see it
there we go there well you know you have
to do some yoga okay
I'm not as nimble as you are now well I
know that's uh it's it's it's from an
Old Gaelic chalice and so it's quite
elaborate that's right it has my
children's birthdays okay that's why you
were so offended when I made a joke
about it I remember you said something
about Gaelic and I said what if it says
like hey this guy's Gaelic and you
looked at me like very sad argument
socialists I remember arguing idiots
because I started my career those in
2009 and I really loved that I remember
that book was kind of what put me on the
path to learning more and I use it as a
reference in my Detroit video or I used
the references from your book that one
specifically addressed the idea of
hybrid cars and how they were actually
losing manufacturers money on each one
sold even the Prius I believe up until
2009 I don't know what it is right now
so it was really I mean I know a lot of
people know you for your style and your
you know you're more of an op ed person
but there was there was some information
there that I think really would have
served people well so this year this is
similar because I mean argument idiots
obviously different arguing with
socialist this sounds redundant right so
it's really not different just updated
idiots to socialist yes Stephen this is
the reason why what you just said is
what I've heard about that book for ten
years it was really effective for people
that were your age at the time
especially yeah because it has you know
a hundred page of really fine print knew
the
footnotes yes at the end so you don't
ever have to quote me you know you have
all of the information there right and
it's also I mean because I'm riddled
with a DD it's also full of charts and
graphs and you know comics and
everything else right and we tried to
look for the the best arguments against
capitalism and so there's no straumann
in here it's not the this you know it's
not the stereotypical conservative just
throwing you know lame complaints about
capitalism and then just robbery you
want to live in China won't you get the
hell out that kind of thing exactly
right yes exactly right yeah tried to
take and and really look because there's
bad things about the free market and
there's bad things about socialism a lot
more over here but you know let's look
at what the real arguments are and if
you have an open mind at all you know
you you want to serve people the best
way you can
so which is the which which one works
which one doesn't and I appreciate the
self-awareness there that you say we
don't have to quote you it doesn't mean
that your arguments are illegitimate at
all but I know for example I always
that's always we why we provide sources
here that are usually the New York Times
and we can learn from PubMed because I
know if someone says well steven crowder
i go to what lets me use a source
because i'm an ass and no one will
listen to you so not that you are but
that's why it but you know that people
will see is biased so you list your
original references which is what really
helped me with arguing with idiots yeah
I remember using them quite a bit than
going on it's yeah you're a complete
idiot if you quote if you quote me or
you quote you right because the media
has done a good job and quite honestly I
have been very effective at smearing
myself as well the media's done a great
job on making us losers or you know
people you can't trust or just hacks
that don't know what they're talking
about so if you believe we do well good
get the book and we've taken all of the
facts from the New York Times at any
time I found something from the Heritage
Foundation I went back to the
researchers and said go find it from a
source that the left
appreciates don't take it from the
Heritage Foundation take it from
something that the left will say okay
well all right it's a New York time
you're right and they came back you're
like not Ana Kasparian go back to the
think tank bring me something useful
this is important because we've done
this you know when we prepare for a
change my mind I sit down with a
brilliant researcher reg who's literally
more than a mental level like you in
squats like 700 series the scariest
person on earth but we always try and
prepare for because we have to right
we're going to go out into it's a
free-for-all it's four hours of anyone
including professors and with socialism
it's very common than saying well
they're socialist elements and so we've
always focused not so much in
totalitarian Marxism but really short of
the Norwegian socialist model I think
you refer to it in your book as the
Swedish style socialism because that's
what's off yeah if the socialism du jour
right they used to point to Canada when
I live in Canada that doesn't work they
used to point to France or maybe belt
legal that doesn't work so now they
point to Sweden can you tell me how you
define that or or or why it something
that you address in the book yeah so
Sweden is a it's not a socialist country
it is more free on its industry than we
are it has fewer regulations it out of
the Norwegian countries I think three of
them have lower taxes than we do yeah it
is not a socialist system it used to be
and then it failed
around the time Baba started to fail
right and they got away from ABBA and
they got away from socialist and then
they brought back and covering ABBA and
they were like shy so they got rid of
that because they couldn't afford it
anymore it wasn't working the taxes were
getting way too high and it was
everything was collapsing so they knew
they had to get out of the socialist
game and they become very very
free-market right I mean a socialist
country doesn't come up with IKEA where
you can buy furniture you have to put
together and have Swedish meatballs
right and no return policy this country
there's no return policy whatsoever it's
like brought a home
was broken you broke it you bought it I
didn't break it it arrived broken no
return policy at all give something
shipped from Ikea you are on your own
and something else too yeah go ahead
no I was just gonna say mostly I mean I
think they break because it's it's just
glued sawdust isn't it oh yeah yeah yeah
they just take sawdust but glue and just
hold it together right yeah it really is
pretty bad but I outfitted my entire
house with IKEA when we first got
married and then I set that's everybody
joked we broke the bed my wife and I and
they're like oh no no just literally
laid down and it snapped right down the
middle and I wish there was some story
it's just bad Swedish design okay
there's nothing it's true true story you
can go up if you can use the time
machine go back on my Twitter so let me
ask you this or to another term we were
just talking in the morning show this
week the Eco socialism is something
that's also kind of a new buzz phrase
they just want to rebrand so you have
democratic socialism Swedish style
socialism eco socialism is another point
that I think if I'm not mistaken you
address in your boat and we hear that
from a osceola yeah in the first in the
in the first chapter I define the words
and I think the most important thing is
that socialism cannot escape its history
and people say all know what those are
communist countries actually communism
has never been done before communism is
not a step that anyone has completed in
fact Soviet Union was the what United or
union of socialist Soviet states right
and so it's a Soviet system is the
socialist system Cuba is a socialist not
communist communism is once there is no
gun behind it once everybody's in that
utopia where we all just put our money
down and we're all working together and
everybody owns everything it's never
gotten there right it never gets past
the socialist part so the important
thing to remember is that socialism is
the part with the guns right if it's not
if you're looking at someplace like
Sweden they would have had to go to guns
if they weren't sweet
go to guns instead they just got rid of
it and went to capitalism right so it's
it's the part that always ends in
Venezuela and nobody will ever admit
that but that's the important thing
well I think it's also important that to
bring them like you said the USSR I mean
a big part of that was Sandals Resorts
didn't want to share their profits they
we have Bernie coming in here on a
honeymoon and listen we we what we kill
it happens it happened the same thing in
Canada you know to a lesser extent where
I lived there under a universal health
care system a socialized health care
system in Quebec and apparently Quebec
is when I did the video back in 2009
Canadian health care people said oh you
were biased you just picked the worst
hospitals in Canada I said the Charla
Moines hospital that's where I went
that's literally down the block from
where this is I went to all the hospital
Nick from my I went to in my
municipality there was no privatized
health care at all
it was illegal until there was a Supreme
Court case in 2005 shall we versus
Quebec and I've talked about this quite
a bit where they said it's a violation
of Human Rights to force people into
these waiting lines and if they want to
pay for care and they are at death's
door they have the right to that didn't
exist when I was there so my mother was
looking at like 11 or 14 months for an
MRI to see a dermatologist was nine
months for me I mean it was incredibly
long and I lived under that and I think
a lot of times people take the most
severe example if it's Mao is China and
I go home saying you don't have to I
think to Americans understanding the
reality of socialism light would be
scary enough mm-hmm I think the what the
you don't hear is for instance right now
under co vid you don't hear the private
sector begging the British government to
please let us make masks let us let us
help you with the vaccine please let us
do this under the NIH in Great Britain
they can't without a government
exception right and the government
doesn't want to make an exception that's
insanity yeah and if you if you really
truly love the socialist system watch
where the vaccine watch where the
medicines come from because they're not
going to be coming
from Venezuela they're not gonna be
coming most likely from Canada they're
gonna be coming from a free market yeah
and we are we are not even the most free
now Sweden when it comes to when it
comes to business
Sweden is more free than we are yeah I
think a lot of people don't know that
again from being a Canadian I remember
when Barack Obama was president Canada
for the first time ever was higher on
the economic freedom index in the United
States and they avoided the housing
bubble because their Prime Minister
Stephen Harper too said wait the whole
thing give loans to people who can't pay
it back because racism or something
we're not gonna do that they still need
25% down and they avoided it so even
this is the one thing - usually when
socialist countries avoid catastrophes
that we face here it's because they're
more conservative on that specific issue
and speaking of that and I want to go to
sort of the the Cova topic obviously if
people look at the death rates per
capita you have to remove like
Luxembourg or I don't know a couple of
small islands but large sized countries
the top four France Italy Spain Belgium
again three years ago these are the
countries that were being praised for
their socialized health care system we
would have to multiply our death rate
per capita by four times to be close to
what they have why aren't people talking
about this it's like to me this is a
great opportunity to look at the perils
of socialized healthcare versus a free
enterprise system I have to tell you
Steven now is the best time to talk
about not only socialized medicine but
also the free market deutsche bank just
came out over the weekend and said their
thing is the free market anymore how did
you pronounce that
Deutsch a Deutsche Bank you do it all
properly chancellor i do with my wife
and we watch the new pope i go I cannot
believe Viola she goes who I saw don't
talk about fight yeah he's my guy that
but yeah so Deutsche Bank got it you
know I feel like an ass how do you say
don't you bake how do you say it I say
Dutch yeah and I know it's wrong and I'm
okay with it
so anyway the German bank just came out
to this this weekend and said that there
is no such thing as a free market
because of what the Fed is done but the
Fed is done is there now the largest
landowner in the world they own all of
our debt they're the biggest Treasury
financed ears now they own more of our
Treasury bonds than anybody else they
are going to end up owning everything in
the end the market is not free anymore
because there is no bottom there's no
real pricing on anything except for the
average person you know what they've
done is they are using modern monetary
theory which is a socialist dream and
it's a chapter six is a chapter that we
almost didn't put in because I thought
huh you know this is kind of far out
there because it would really take a it
would take a real disruption to get
there but I tied it into technology and
I said if you get a jobless problem and
technology along with modern monetary
theory you are a 1984 style State a
George Orwell state right this is the
utopia that the socialists are talking
about modern monetary theory is this new
idea that you don't have to have the
money or even taxes to pay for anything
just print the money yeah oh that sounds
brilliant along with the the technology
that we'll get in bed with the
government to monitor people which we
are doing now
along with joblessness you have a
takeover of the capitalist free system
we've just experienced it we're
experiencing it right now they're not
even they're not even asking for votes
on things in Congress anymore they're
going to an empty room
those opposed the eyes have it right
nobody's in Congress how are they voting
on these bills it is a scary thought I
don't usually reference uh Orwell much
you know why cuz I might read about on
it's like I don't like him he was a he
was a socialist who then kind of turned
and he was like
what about Catalina China the place that
was like a socialist a narco socialists
Indyk is immediately were wiped out
don't like it think you're full of it
not you or well but let me ask you this
you know a lot about the Fed and you
know a lot more about like you focused
on this quite a bit what have you
justify about this point to say okay
China we're not paying you back until
you sort this out
there's even feasible what we're gonna
pay on that war but yeah but you know
what their little uh yeah in physical
stature not money do I should build
bombs they could drop Chinese people
from the sky and win right so that's
true and the fact is that when you look
at how much the government cares about
their citizens they would be the ones
doing that that's unfortunate thing I
want to be really clear salutely would
Pro Chinese people having rights so I'm
anti Chinese government no but go ahead
exactly right exactly right and I will
tell you the the strategy that China had
to beat Russia in a war was take a
million troops March them across the
border and surrender next day million
troops surrender next day a million
troops by day three they've been
overwhelmed just by people so the lower
intestines brilliant Rajan or I think
yeah I think that they are I think this
has been as close to an active act of
war that anyone else has ever
perpetrated on I think you're writing
other countries in the world I mean they
have killed more people than we lost in
World War one lost more people than than
the Vietnam War I don't know I think it
sounds one thing if they said war you've
destroyed our economy yeah maybe well
we've destroyed our economy with their
help to be fair but I think it would be
different if they said like our bad no
more wet markets but instead they're
like no no no no no no and they blame it
on us like takes if they took some
responsibility nothing is unforgivable
but these practices when we talk about
the been reopened sorry go ahead
Steven they're also they're also wildly
your response
well not just with the wet market but
what they're all of the things that they
denied all of the information they
withheld and now they're going to
countries like France and France send
them a bunch of PPEs and and masks and
everything else now France needs some
China is not only not returning those
masks right they are selling them the
masks and saying you can only buy them
if you take our 5g rights that's insane
I know it's like it's a hostile actor
it's like the IKEA return policy of
global trade it is all ass Fleury that
is unacceptable and have a broken bed
frame to prove it we've tie into all
this but sooner or later I want some
Swede to answer though for IKEA I know a
lot of people may not like obviously you
are not a big Trump guy in the primaries
neither was i but at this point when
we're looking at Biden and you're
looking at Donald Trump how would you
rate how the president has handled this
and and what you think his chances are
going into 2020 compared to by bottle I
think Hyden is I can't believe that
Biden is actually gonna be the guy
there's no way he's actually the guy I
think it's governor nipple ring there's
no way that Biden doesn't know where he
is no he can't be President no I think
it's one of those things when he
actually gets to the convention
everybody will be like okay come on guys
I mean he was a placeholder right
there's somebody else so I don't think
he'll be the guy if he is he loses
Donald Trump I think I wasn't a fan of
his but I've grown to be a fan of his
and then on top of it the media has made
me even more of a fan of his right
because they've been so grossly unfair
and just really sick yeah what they're
doing now I think he's done a really
good job I like the fact that he has
pushed all of the power back to the
states that he hasn't taken you know any
of the opportunity to nationalize
anything yeah I don't like the spending
but I also don't like shutting down the
economy and it's constant
- I think that's important I know that
cos eople you've taken it from as people
who were both against the bailouts in
the big stimulus bill when we talked
about you in 2009 where we sort of to
know each other that is very different
from the government stepping in and
saying shut down your business
hey everybody else do not go to that
business or a church or we will find you
you prohibit people from making a living
restitution there is not the same as
simply paying out businesses that we're
going to go bankrupt anyway that's it
right I think you only to understand
that's never been incongruent with a
conservative worldview at all no the
government is the government is the
responsible player on the failure of all
of these businesses that will fail all
of the unemployment that we had over
three and a half percent is because of
the federal government and their action
right and when they take away your right
to be you know even in some cases stupid
you know I want to be in New York City
and I'm gonna have my hot dog stand
right there in front of a hospital if
they take away your right to do it then
they owe you the money that you could
have earned absolutely it would be like
if your nan key took a condemning dump
that is if he took if Bernanke took a
steaming dump right in the middle of a
Cracker Barrel table right in the middle
of the the general store and then walked
away laughing oh no Bernanke you got to
pay for this you're the one who took the
you took the giant steaming crap right
here this wasn't us
no one's coming here because of your
dumb no my knickknacks are dirty yeah
where do I put the biscuits I don't know
algae that drives at home but I tried I
think that I think that I don't think
you can say anything else because 25
minutes in the book is arguing with
socialists it's available wherever books
are sold of course Amazon if you have a
Barnes & Noble cafe that happens to be
open go there wear a mask show oh god no
oh god no no no did you train together
yourself no no
it just comes with a pen and cliffnotes
it's like see if you can reconstitute
this
alright well listen Glenn I know you're
busy we are busy I appreciate it and I
am going to once you send this book I am
going to read I'm a little sore - oh
absolutely
Thank You Glenn all right we have to go
everybody we will see you tomorrow
morning
good morning mutt Club
[Music]